[Music]
all right y'all we're gonna get into a
little detail right now about the glenn
maxwell case okay
jeffrey epstein's former housekeeper
reveals a list of degrading rules that
the staff were made to follow by galen
i was reading
this whole interview well not interview
but the transcript on court
it's [ __ ] wild yeah what was the
wildest the wildest thing is like
going into the
to these rooms and then there's pictures
of them with like underage girls
and also well we couldn't see the
pictures but in court they showed them
and then the people that saw them they
say that yeah clearly it's it's
different when you hear stories of
underage but like when you see it it's
sickening
the the housekeepers they would go in
their sex toys all this stuff and then
um there's confirmation from the staff
the pilot all that yeah of different
world leaders that they saw oh
they're like confirmed all of them yeah
from like bill clinton from like [ __ ]
prince
confirmed and then you know that black
book and this is post him getting
convicted
for um the 1999-2004 stuff yeah so
that's what they're going to trial for
right now but
after he got popped for um
sex trafficking all that stuff sex
sexual abuse to minors
i guess he they didn't prosecute him
federally so then he kind of
kind of got away with it
no um
he's already he's already been popular
he's already been pop but then all these
people bill clinton uh
even trump
bill gates all these people were still
associating with him even after
all this stuff has come out so that's
the big thing like why are you hanging
out with this guy when he's been
prosecuted for
literally sex trafficking minors you
know i um i saw like under that like um
there were people i guess saying
so there's there are trump supporters
who said that like
well
there's a picture of trump with them and
he was on the plane but he cut off
communication after 1990-something
and then there is a confirmed case where
uh epstein was banned on trump property
so when he was there at mar-a-lago or
some [ __ ] like that on one of the trump
properties they kicked him off
and then
trump came out i think in the 2000s and
said oh yeah the epstein guy he likes
real he likes really young girls like
out in the open yeah so then i guess
what the trump supporters are saying is
that they're like well dude like once
trump found out
he wasn't having anything to do with it
and he even told the world that epstein
was a
like a like a pedophile
he didn't say it outright but he said
obviously like yeah he likes really
young girls so that's that's one
interesting i guess little piece of it
and then because there's no one else
coming out to back up bill clinton
there's no one else
in media talking about anything else but
that's kind of interesting there yeah
yeah
so this uh former housekeeper has taken
the stand on the fourth day of the
maxwell sex trafficking trial and was
revealed how he and other staff members
would live under a booklet of degrading
rules this dude's name is juan alessi
the man in question this he worked for
the convicted sex offender and the
accused at the accused epstein's palm
residence and from there that beach
mansion between 1990 to december 2002.
so he was there for 12 years
upon questioning by the prosecutor
unless he described the working culture
in the palm beach mansion which included
a 50-h page booklet on how to behave
something the housekeeper recalled as
being degrading wow okay the booklet
which was submitted into evidence was
released today showing the strict rules
staff members were told to follow
included were the orders unobtrusive is
the key smile never disclose mr epstein
or ms maxwell's activities or
whereabouts to anyone and see nothing
say nothing these are like actual rules
that are in the booklet and now this
booklet is obviously out and about so
wow those don't seem degrading though
those first couple rules i feel like any
any like i don't know elite hollywood
establishment like if you're a assistant
working at caa or something like that's
probably the first four rules nda type
[ __ ] that's true because you can't have
staff going oh my god mr bill clinton oh
my god can i get a picture with you yeah
you know what i mean like
oh my god what's up dude chris tucker
what's up dude
they don't go into super details of the
list but there are for example maxwell
also told her staff to never look
epstein in the eyes okay that's the
gradient to answer questions he asked
looking away from him uh staff were
reportedly so crazy they're not allowed
to eat or drink in front of maxwell as
well as wear strong perfume or
aftershave lotion
sometimes these people aren't sick these
people are sick [ __ ] he also revealed
that he had to drive and collected a
young girl from school and brought her
to maxwell in 94. that that was the
weird one yeah he then alleged that
maxwell instructed him to regularly
drive her to visit epstein's house so he
had to like continually drive this girl
back and forth yikes the jury heard
alessi say that the girl seemed 14 or 15
and was strikingly beautiful and she was
later identified as jane the pseudonym
for one of the women [ __ ] who has
accused epstein of years of sexual abuse
yeah jane also testified that maxwell
was sometimes present during her abuse
and participated in the sex acts
so yeah i mean i'm guessing from a
housekeeper's point of view like you can
probably put a couple things you know
two and two together but then obviously
under the you know the rules you can't
say do or speak about anything he falls
in line with all the other testimonies
from all the other victims too like they
would say the same [ __ ] same patterns
all that so
yeah like at first one that when i heard
about the trunks gonna start off i was
like worried i was like man i wonder if
she's actually gonna get away with it
yeah because the whole thing the whole
defense is they get to be like well
she's getting punished for jeffrey
epstein's crimes so her main defense
strategy is to say oh that was all him
like i didn't do any of this
but she was like his [ __ ] recruiter
dude she was grooming these these girls
like and participated the jane doe the
girl the 14 year old her story is crazy
her dad died
and then
her mom was the only parent but
apparently she was sick
didn't have any money and it was and i
guess they met at a school fundraiser or
something so epstein would go to these
fundraisers and probably seek out
these and he was scouting he was
scouting bro like he was out
and
he he uses the money to leverage this
girl and then to slowly bring her on and
then started abusing her and did it
until she was 16.
so yeah and then everyone and then their
whole defense is
oh well why didn't you come out earlier
like why what how come now you're coming
here are we scared of course
it's not even probably exactly like when
you're abused like you don't like when
you're 16 yeah or 14 even going
sometimes when you're going through you
don't even know you're exactly exactly
until you actually like think back and
you're like yeah
you're so in shock you're like oh [ __ ]
you don't even know what to do and
especially when you're trying to use the
defense of like oh like i was like she's
almost in a way saying that she's a
victim of jeffrey epstein to like kind
of pass the blame but at the same time
her defense is
negating these girls experiences of like
oh well why don't you come out oh now
you you want to come on now for five
million dollars
like what i want to see is uh it's crazy
not just her like get what she deserves
but all the other like world leaders
that are tied to prince andrew i would
love to see everyone get tied into it
i'm out like you know when they rico
like a organization like the mafia they
pull down all the heads at the same time
yeah i would love to see some [ __ ]
that's why um i was watching this whole
i think it was on joe rogan but he was
like a journalist right
and then joe rogan was asking him like
why does no one want to touch this it
seems like a conspiracy like it's big
news none of the media agent nobody goes
well there's certain things in media
that you know it's like not worth it and
it's too risky for journalists to touch
even though
it's not something that is openly talked
about but you kind of know that
somewhere up the line it'll piss
somebody off so you don't [ __ ] touch
it and they're suppressing it yeah and
then so like during that time too like
who knows trump could be connected
because during that time it was during
the trump administration right the whole
epstein ship blown up
they have ties together they have
pictures together so if all parties like
if we say from the establishment
leadership right like the old republican
guard the democrats
everybody who was like rich and famous
have some [ __ ] form of picture with
epstein been on his plane hung out with
them so like even if somebody didn't do
anything wrong just by the association
of it now you're tarnished and i think
that's why everyone was like oh [ __ ]
dude let's all do what we can to not
touch this [ __ ] because who knows in
mainstream media like
how many ceos how many people that own
the [ __ ] company have some type of
tie to epstein we don't know and i think
that's why everyone's just like oh i
don't know because then it's not just
one group it was like the republican
democrats rich people everybody
everybody every [ __ ] industry and
that's the sick thing take them all down
honestly dude to be honest
we need a [ __ ] fresh start you know
what i mean dude do you think um his
suicide was an inside job or i think
from the top or i think it was an inside
job it probably was yeah i think his
jail mate
was tired to [ __ ] kill him and you
know what's funny is he's using the
inmate that killed uh epstein allegedly
i'm just going to say the the buff guy
right he's now using galen's lawyer no
way yeah
and if you trace the security guards
that fell asleep and all these things
it's just interesting that's like some
mob [ __ ] where that one lawyer or
consequence is representing everyone
from the same organization it's like
what's the coincidence here no because i
was looking into that and um for
preparation in this article and um i was
like damn everything just happened to
fail at the right time when the cameras
went out like there just happens to be
this like what is that like it's just
like coincidence yeah just the
coincidence like like the bed sheet just
happened to be right there for him they
don't got ryan changing the cameras
no camera guards fell asleep oh no he
he's a he's he he killed himself oh no
yeah oh how we gonna get the evidence
now in a uh in a 2005 interview with
palm beach police alessi this uh
housekeeper admitted he washed a variety
of sex toys including a long rubber
penis after a young girl visited epstein
for a massage
he would also remake the bed after every
massage epstein had which according to
alessi's trial testimony occurred three
times a day towards the end of his
employment and were scheduled by maxwell
damn he's a good libido
well i mean it's getting worked out all
the time right
on the timings of the supposed massages
the now 72 year old stated it was at all
times massages in the morning massages
in the afternoon some massages after
dinner after the movies they were 10 11
o'clock at night
so he also testified that he saw
virginia roberts another woman who
accused the deceased convicted pedophile
of sexual abuse when she was a child
regularly at epstein's house so
if you guys uh saw the documentaries
that covered this stuff
like epstein was already um convic not
convicted he was being charged of this
[ __ ] in florida and then there was that
detective tied to it they wanted to take
him down and then like
they couldn't
i forgot exactly why
but then it just kind of fell through
and then he just kind of escaped and
then a lot of people were just like well
[ __ ] this guy's untouchable yeah i think
i think there was pressure to not
prosecute him on a federal level that's
why it kind of got swept follow the
money but also there's some people
there's some theories that the reason
why they're only charging him
well they're only charging lane for the
1999 to like 2004 stuff is because all
this stuff the way crazier
more uh
controversial conspiracy stuff happened
post 2004
so i guess what they're trying to
they're trying to get him on this now
to see if that anything will stick and
gillane before they probably even
attempt to use those
i just want to see the book like
i just wanna yeah like i think they're
bringing that out
in court and i want to know the roster
of human beings that were on it is this
the one where they wrote their name down
when they were in the airplane is that
the one you're talking about the log
the log the lolita express
oh yeah and then who went to the uh
epstein island yeah
what if he's still alive
chilling with like two pots somewhere
yeah
they're on his island together yeah
yeah we know right
because i think the whole game that
they're doing was
get a bunch of powerful people over and
if you like to party come party with me
epstein the coolest guy around quote
unquote and then they would have them
sleep with underage girls and then film
it and be like oh got you now you're in
my pocket what's next you know that's
one of the theories of um
why they did this it's like one it could
be just a prostitution service where
it's like a discreet way for the rich
and famous can come have fun do all the
drugs and [ __ ] that they want right
they could stay on the island they could
[ __ ] each other or they can [ __ ]
whatever that's one theory another one
was
they found out that the original
apartment out in new york and other
places had a lot of cameras rigged so
the other theory secret room yes
is that they would blackmail the rich
and famous by getting them to have sex
with underage girls and then they'd be
like we got this on you so now you do
what we want you to do both sound
possible isn't maxwell's dad like a
powerful figure dude that's another
thing so he's mossad
which is uh the cia of israel but he's
also [ __ ] kgb
and her sisters are very welcoming
there's like a rich billionaire too
isn't he like yeah new zealand her
sister's devi i think they designed the
uh
the
program for like the i think it's the
pentagon or something so like they're
high level intelligence on her sisters
so it's like i don't it probably goes
away so she's going to get off the hook
she might but i don't know this [ __ ] is
stacked or it could be they use we're
using her to blackmail the people they
need to get
play ball or whatever because her dad
her dad's story they're saying that this
is how it really went down like the
conspiracy theorist is like her dad
is um he's like a triple agent right so
he grew up in i think ukraine or
whatever as like a ukrainian jewish kid
and then so he worked under the soviet
government but he moved to um
the uk and then from there he became
like a special
[ __ ] 007 type but then he's also
ethnically jewish or something so he
worked for mossad which is the cia of
israel and so he was like a triple agent
doing all this crazy [ __ ] and then he
owned um a publication it's like owning
the washington post or something like
that and he was doing a lot of different
disinformation [ __ ] through there wow so
then like
from there he uh something happened
where he went on this like
special trip on a yacht and he died and
galen was like nah he got killed he
didn't kill himself
and then
they're saying that her dad was the
puppet master of her
and she teamed up with epstein and then
epstein was like a broke dude like he
was like some teacher at a school and
all of a sudden he became this big
[ __ ] non-profit like money out of
nowhere that social life yeah so that's
why there's a lot of weird question
marks of people used to question how did
this guy get all his money and how is he
so powerful didn't he didn't he get
about being a like main apprentice slash
like finance person for that other
leslie the guy who created the the
limited to which is another [ __ ]
weird thing which is limited to it was
like it was a teenage thing teenage girl
jeans thing or whatever yeah use that to
like to holler at girls underage girls
on that side too but apparently he he
took a bunch of money from him
so it's it's there's some hedge fund
guys that came on podcasts and then
they're talking about their first-hand
account with epstein and they're like
you know what this whole thing felt like
great gatsby like this guy like so like
when you're at that level right you can
see how like the difference is between
millionaires and billionaires and he
goes this guy was spending like
billionaire cash
but
he acts more like someone that's about
a millionaire yeah and he goes there's a
difference between the two and then he's
like so it was always like oh we kind of
knew that it was fake or weird
and then he was always just having these
big parties and whatever and no one knew
where he got the money from
so the the conspiracy here is that
glenn's dad brought them two together
they created this elaborate plan
he was funded by
one of those agencies and that was their
way
of
trapping and blackmailing rich and
famous and powerful people and i'm like
[ __ ]
that is a crazy web man
you